she went through okay hold up
how many oopsies is this out of 10
oopsies one of the biggest generational
leaps in gaming just happened unreal
engine 5 just dropped there's one
specific shot that is like an actual
like huh
big thanks to bessie shoes for
sponsoring today's episode at the end of
this video i'll tell you how you can get
25
off your own pair of vessy shoes
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of vfx artist react we have so
many cool clips to show you today and
something that's not even from a movie
but still it's going to redefine
everything about filmmaking all right
crack your budweisers because it's time
to react classic saturday morning
budweiser
is just me
just me we had to repaint this budweiser
here so it looks like a lacroix but
really
you're the best we're the beautiful
we're the only
the host
purgatory guardians
[Laughter]
so real quick no computers all right
think about how these shots are done
without computers
[Applause]
the animation's really good on these
ghosts
whoa
i saw some like skew going on on that
ghost
[Music]
whoa wait hold up
yeah she went through okay hold up
that was a really tricky shot isn't it
it's one thing to have a person like be
dangling from their feet and going
across the room but she went through a
doorway and the doors closed after her
there's a couple pretty pretty cool
magic tricks happening here and i want
to throw two of them at you guys and see
if you guys can guess how they're done
so first off we have the ghost the first
part is pretty straightforward you're
like oh they probably filmed on a green
screen technically it's a blue screen
those are costumes full sized costumes
that a human being is wearing say these
animatronic heads so you don't have a
computer how do you get it to stretch
and warp right it's like you just take
your piece of film and stretch and warp
your piece of film okay i'm gonna make a
guess it's some sort of re-exposing a
projection that they're adding real life
skew to like if you were to project
something onto a wall and then like
continue to project it upwards it's
gonna like skew outwards a bit that's a
close guess it's actually
a little more clever than that more
clever notice how his legs go to a point
like you're not that's not skew that's
not just perspective skew they're
actually warping the image oh that's
like a liquid type thing oh i see what
you're saying i didn't even notice
that's weird oh how do you do that
optically so here's how they did it they
took their dude on a blue screen or
whatever punch out the blue screen so
you just have your background that's
just black and they put this on a
projection screen and then they set up a
mylar sheet mylar is like the uh those
like balloons those like metallica yeah
like a space blanket yeah or basically
so they actually thermally reflective
the literally
grab somewhere over there oh yeah mylar
mylar so they had this sheet it was a
little bit thicker than this it wasn't
just like fabric and so they have the
the projection i don't know if you can
see like my hands here so they have the
projection here and then the reflection
of the projection on the mylar and then
they had computer controlled motion
controlled rods that would push on the
mylar to disrupt and distort the
reflection and they could program it so
you get squashes and stretches so kind
of like a house of mirrors type deal
exactly like a house on your side deal
it's like the actual physical version of
doing a mesh distortion yeah like these
days you just click and drag some pixels
but back then they had to prod and poke
photons yeah so the final images we're
seeing here were captured on reflective
plastic yes oh my god the second big
magic trick in the scene the prosecutor
being dragged out of the courtroom by
her leg by a ghost okay there's
something i definitely noticed right
away there's a black outline around her
leg that looks like a track matte
artifact so she's not in the scene at
all are you sure because look at the
hands you were doing so well rent wait
okay okay no no you're right
lighting all matches up so that leads me
to believe she is there but she's being
cut out somehow the thing is is that if
they're going to do this wire stunt the
top of the wall can't really be there
because they need to be able to drag her
through this situation see the black
lines above the sconces i think that's
where the set ends it's basically a real
wall and a false wall see yeah even the
lighting is a little bit off what they
ended up doing here is the little black
line there that's where the real footage
from that shot ends and then above that
is a little miniature has been
photographed and stuck back onto the
footage to cover up the area where the
wire went through i mean they did a
really good job matching that angle yeah
they not only like lined up the
perspective perfectly they lined up the
exposure perfectly and they timed the
strobe lights to link together it's not
perfect you can actually frame by frame
you can see where the strobes don't
quite line up perfectly between but when
you watch it in motion it's not even an
issue yeah having the ghost and all the
electricity really helps blend it the
funny thing is in other shots where you
see that door the miniature is actually
different than
the actual on location shot it's close
though that's pretty close when you
watch these older visual effects shots
and you see stuff like this it's hard to
like understand how much ingenuity has
to go into these shots whereas these
days these days
you do a shot like this in a film and
you watch it you're not like wow how did
they do that because you can always just
fall back on ah it's just a bunch of cg
whatever there's something pretty
special about this in a way it forces
you to really commit to your shots
that's what you're gonna work with and
that's the piece you're gonna execute on
for the next couple months in a way
maybe it's good that we have that
flexibility now we don't have to commit
quite as much but it makes it like a
very structured like theatrical play in
a way it's a different style of
movie-making
i see
trees of green
let's watch this goof are we looking at
a goof yep so doolittle which was a bit
of a box office bomb has some legit
amazing effects in it but the part we're
gonna look at here
has some jank
give us five minutes if you don't feel
better you could fry it stop talking
he like clips through the side of the
dragon's neck it's so strange
it comes back out they're stitching two
takes together and i think that's the
motivation for this because see how far
away he is then he goes back
and then the dragon talks and it pans
back and it's like super close i think
that's part of it i think another issue
is that they're getting this shot of
robert downey jr working on the dragon
they want to like show more the dragon
here but they didn't rotate the camera
when they're filming robert downey jr so
his perspective stays the same it's like
you could put your finger on his eyeball
and then the camera moves and your
finger would still be on his eyeball
it's like someone forgot to parent his
layer to the track
yeah that's totally just like an
oversight there that's weird man it's a
bummer because like the rest of the shot
actually looks really good like the
creature work here the lighting the
rendering the depth of field it's all
like pretty well done it's kind of fun
to be able to pick on one shot
yeah i know
it feels a little unfair like it's a
little look at this whole movie it's
like oh this one little mistake happened
and it's not even yeah i gotcha it's a
pretty tiny mistake too it's not like
when you said he was gonna clip through
the dragon i was imagining i was gonna
see robert downey jr halfway inside of a
dragon
how many oopsies is this out of 10
oopsies it's subtle most people probably
didn't notice it this is like a solid 5
out of 10.
[Music]
this has to be
guys one of the biggest generational
leaps in gaming just happened unreal
engine 5 just dropped and they just
dropped this video demonstrating what
makes it crazy and this doesn't just
apply to unreal engine this applies to
the entire industry this is going to
change filmmaking not only as we know it
this is also like changing how we
approach 3d programs in general
the portal is open there's so much
detail this is what the lion king looked
like look at that
and this is in real time and guarantee
the lion king was not in real time let
me explain some problems here all right
so when we're talking about unreal
engine versus cinema 4d 3ds max maya
like the traditional 3d modeling and
animation programs there's a big
difference how are these mountains even
made in the first place well you might
use cinema 4d to make the photo scan of
one or two of the rocks but you're
making each individual
tiny file in a traditional application
and then bringing them in into unreal
where you can view them all at the same
time but we're not tweaking the
individual polygons and vertices that
actually make up the foundation of that
model and so because of that they don't
have to display
all the model to you that's why this
technology doesn't exist in those
programs yet is because it's just a
different needs structure in those
traditional ones you try and open this
giant mountain landscape your computer
might explode anyone trying to work with
the 3d scene has the limitations of what
their machine is it can only handle so
many polygons if you have a really high
resolution mesh of a character you
import the character and then you don't
have room for anything else in the shot
so you have to optimize what you have
the reason why unreal 5 is a big deal is
they figured out how to have all the
geometry you could possibly want but
still have it run really efficiently the
team over at epic came up with a system
called nanite it lets you take these
incredibly highly detailed models the
kind that you would see like in a film
like remember king kong like that detail
of a model unless you bring that into a
video game and run it through the system
and then have that geometry merge
together and become simplified as it
backs away so you never can see that
change in detail as things get further
into the distance they're becoming
simpler and the computer's not having to
pull all that data and likewise it gets
closer to the camera it starts filling
all the data back in and that's crazy
because not only does it change how
video games are going to be made moving
forwards it kind of changes a little bit
how movies are going to be made so let's
say you're shooting on a green screen
set okay well what is that going to look
like is the lighting going to affect my
characters what's going to happen here
how should i frame things when we have
access to technology like this it
bridges that gap of going from hey three
months later you get to see what this
huge awesome city looks like to
literally you can run a laptop next to
your camera that can in real time at 60
frames per second see the entire
detailed city that you'll be putting in
your background so you are witnessing us
crossing a technological edge we're
gonna stop measuring things in seconds
per frame and we're gonna start
measuring them in frames per second it's
kind of crazy to think about where we've
come from just in the last like 20 25
years because remember that movie final
fantasy spirits within i'm standing
waiting for something
i swear it looks like a cut scene no it
does it looks like i could see 100 but
when i saw it originally i was just like
how can video game graphics get better
yeah it's like we're there there's like
no room for improvement it's perfect
this was a mind-blowing movie at the
time this was probably one of the most
ambitious movies because they committed
to having everything be a hundred
percent cg not just computer driven they
ended up inventing over a hundred
plug-ins to work with maya to be able to
make this film happen
[Music]
but it must be done
every facial animation was all done by
hand through keyframes and sliders they
actually look pretty good like that's
probably where a lot of the time went
there's a couple things that are really
holding them back one is subsurface
scattering and that is the light
entering your skin scattering and then
coming back out from your skin if you
don't have subsurface scattering for
skin skin ends up looking like it's
plastic and that was the thing for all
the cg in the 90s these are the people
who are like opening this giant gate
that the rest of the world now gets to
walk through and that is you know
awesome cg animated films
it's saturday morning it's subscriber
appreciation day and if you're not
subscribed well
come join us next saturday and if you're
not subscribed well i don't appreciate
you
no i'm kidding i appreciate every single
one of you watching this video every
single one including kevin
we settled our grievances and now we're
buds
[Music]
one movie i wanted to look at was army
of the dead because there's a lot of
cool visual stuff that is being done
throughout it notably the fact that they
replaced
an actor that was in the entire film to
the point where dave bautista who plays
the lead role has yet to actually meet
her despite being in many many scenes
with the character so i haven't seen
this yet and i don't know who was
replaced i'm gonna see if i can spot
them all right let's see
team's all here lovely to have you oh i
think i can tell
wait what i missed it it's very subtle
it's very subtle this shot right here
nico who is it it's the girl that's
standing in front of dave batista
she wasn't the actress that was replaced
for the whole film maybe in this one
shot they had to do some tweaking but
it's actually the one to her left oh
really yeah see the white wrap i did a
really good job the lightroom actually
doesn't look too bad to me because yeah
tinting blue it's the edge blur i think
the edge blur is a little too strong you
know now that you say it though like
there is something a little obtuse about
how she's standing in front of him maybe
like her hair is too sharp or something
and maybe she also had to be replaced in
that shot to make the other one work oh
cause you have overlap and paint outs to
do that's the thing once you start
replacing
one person you quickly get into this
territory of well what was behind them
that now had to be replaced
see she's replaced there in the corner
too oh they did a great job that's great
wow yeah that's really well so well done
matching the depth of field and the
focus change there's one specific shot
that is like an actual like huh so here
we go watch this even to triage what do
you mean well i mean wow dang is the
most important look at the hair do you
get the green screen
the lighting change well the tracking
anytime you add a moving camera to the
mix
it gets a little bit more complicated i
make this a lot more complicated
especially if you need to
film someone after the fact when you
already recorded a scene with moving
camera like do you film them again in
real life with a motion controlled
camera replicating your camera's motion
but how do you even get the camera's
motion when you look at that like the
lens is so foggy and there's so much
depth of field going on here see like
all the light wrap and stuff and the
haze and bloom we're getting they're
also nailing the actual lighting
direction and the silhouette and the
actual occlusion as she gets further
away from that light that all matches
very well this is expert level like
manipulation of light it's not like 3d
work where you can just like check all
the boxes that enable like 100
physically based realistic rendering
you're filming on a camera which
immediately takes it out of the realm of
science and into the artistry because
how your camera's been interpreting that
image and then we're going to take that
you know now no longer physically based
100 simulated shot and now i'm going to
composite that and match the focus i'm
going to mash the lighting and match the
bloom i'm going to match the
imperfections i'm going to match the
motion you only make it look real by
putting in the work and having the
foresight in the planning and the
knowledge and the craftsmanship you hear
that and you immediately think of
superman's mustache you're like we
replaced an actor and you're like oh god
here we go
and it's basically perfect i think it's
worth seeing
the coolest the movie has to offer which
is in the title sequence
[Music]
oh my god that's extremely gory this is
very gory that's why i wanted to show it
to you
hey zach if you uh ever watch our show
we'd love to have you on it it'd be
really cool
[Music]
so the t-1000 groundbreaking at the time
it honestly still holds up in a ton of
shots and like shots have emotional
impact too i hate that floor shot only
because you tried recreating it and it
was hard it was super hard
[Laughter]
while we could go in depth with the
visual effects in this episode we
decided to make an entire video
dedicated to going in depth and
recreating some of terminator 2's best
visual effects so what we decided to do
was a full deep dive investigation into
one of those shots in particular the
jail bar scene shot peter and i we try
to recreate it with a couple different
methods it's really fascinating check it
out it's coming out on this channel
tomorrow subscribe or you know just come
back tomorrow
hello everyone and welcome back to the
brandio daniel special here on bfx
artist react today courtesy of today's
sponsor vesey shoes we're going to be
seeing if we can float this shoe
down this stream without getting the
little piece of paper that i've placed
inside of it wet in any way a lot of you
guys didn't believe us when we told you
that bessie shoes were waterproof and
this is the chance to prove it to you
all once and for all all right here we
go there's a little waterfall down there
here's the stream okay here we go
go my child
okay while we get this set up there's a
few things that you guys got to know
about vessies now obviously when they're
on your foot they are 100 percent
waterproof and weatherproof you can wear
them through any weather and keep your
toes dry rain snow mud slush you name it
these shoes are also incredibly
breathable their patented material lets
the sweat and heat escape keeping your
toes fresh and the incredible dimetex
material that they're made of keeps you
warm in the winter and cool in the
summer they're highly stretchy they fit
like a sock so you barely even notice
that you're wearing anything at all
vessies are the best travel shoe out
there so whether you're caught in a
storm walking through town or on and off
at airports vessies will meet all of
your needs
[Music]
well that didn't work so well
okay so give them a break no one said
that the shoes were boats or that they
would float down a stream without
getting a piece of paper inside of it
wet no one ever said that but vessies
are waterproof when they're on your foot
so if you guys are interested head on
over to vesey.com corridor crew and
you'll get 25
off your first purchase that's betsy
footwear.com corridor crew but anyways i
think we all learned something here
today let me know next time what you
want to see in the brandio daniels
special and now back to the episode i've
been wanting to do some sort of like
special effects episode at some point
soon but we need some stuff to look at
so leave a comment down below of some of
the best special effects not cgi or
visual effects especially make a very
real special and then maybe we'll get a
cool guest on to look at him with us bye
everybody
bye bye
in this very minute